[Music]
your baby is your most prized possession
you can sanitize childproof and Pad all
you want but there's only one way to
truly keep your baby safe really what is
it introducing baby safe the first and
only safe for your baby it's a
well-known fact that a safe is the
safest place to keep things safe with
baby safe we always know our baby is
safe because she's in a safe it's also a
great place to keep my jewelry safes are
actually where we get the word safe so
when people say their baby is at home
safe and she's not in an actual safe is
she really safe we used her birthday as
the combination July
15th and it's not just for babies from
the makers of baby safe comes toddler
safe I'm heading out
buddy the perfect way to turn the
terrible twos into the terrific twos in
a safe hey
it's great knowing he's safe plus it's
soundproof sometimes I put him in there
when he's acting like a real and
safety isn't just for the home sorry can
I help you with that man yes thank you
so much now there's travel baby safe the
perfect safe for when you're traveling
with a baby and want to put the baby
you're traveling with in a safe you got
it
[Music]
thanks
baby safe toddler safe and travel baby
safe because you can never go too far in
keeping your baby safe even if you're
literally putting it inside of a
repurposed Bank safe baby safe your baby
is in a safe from the makers of
adolesent safe honey do you need help
with your homework mom get out of my
safe I'm
[Music]
sorry